-Well, the knives are out
in the GOP
as Republicans begin to bicker
with each other
and look for someone to blame
after their party collapsed
in Tuesday's midterms
and Joe Biden had
the best midterm showing
of any sitting president
in 20 years.
Republicans and right-wing media
are blaming everything
from voting machines
to young people, to women
and, perhaps most shockingly,
they're really pissed
at Donald Trump.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
You know,
going into these midterms,
I was never nervous.
I knew anything was possible.
I was bracing for the worst.
But one thing that made me
feel better
was knowing that we had
patriots out there,
making sure our elections
were running smoothly.
Patriots like MyPillow
CEO Mike Lindell,
[ Laughter ]
who announced,
before the election,
that his team
would be monitoring every race
across the country for fraud
through his website,
which has, as you would expect,
a ridiculous name --
frankspeech.com.
-We're going to be watching
every race.
We're going to have
the real-time crime desk going
at frankspeech.com.
[ Laughter ]
Everybody can watch me there
tomorrow night.
We are tracking every race
by cyber.
I want all the bad guys
out there to know,
through the Edison Report,
we are watching
and we also have
another way to watch
what's going on with the
computers and the machines,
so, I'm putting them all
on notice, Steve.
They're all on notice.
-Hear that, bad guys?
[ Laughter ]
You are on notice.
Mike Lindell is tracking
every race by cyber.
[ Laughter ]
Why is all of his computer
lingo 30 years old?
[ As Lindell ]
We're tracking
the bad guys by cyber
and using AOL Instant Messenger
to find out
[ Laughter ]
their age/sex/location.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Lindell always talks like
he's being forced
to write a science fiction novel
at gunpoint.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Lindell ]
But I, I don't know anything
about science fiction.
"Well, then I guess this is
goodbye, Lindell."
[ As Lindell ]
There were robots and machines
[ Laughter ]
who were using cyber
to be, uh, bad guys.
[ Laughter ]
And mankind's only hope was
the Edison Project,
led by the fearless astronaut
Frank Speech.
[ Laughter ]
So, Lindell said he was tracking
every race through cyber.
He even said,
during a livestream
on election night,
when the host tried
to wrap things up,
that he would stay there
and keep tracking votes
all night.
-I think Mike is back.
Mike, we were starting
to make up wrap-up comments
for the evening.
What do you think?
-I didn't know we were
wrapping up comments.
I got General Flynn coming on
and we got a video of Kari Lake
40 minutes ago.
-[ Laughs ]
-I don't know if you guys --
I'm staying up all night
'til we win!
-I don't think
it's great advertising
that a pillow salesman never
seems to want to go to bed.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Lindell ]
I'm pulling a back-to-back
all-nighter,
anything not to put my head
on that lumpy sack of wrenches.
[ Laughter ]
They smell like burnt rubber.
You won't be surprised
to hear that, on Tuesday,
when it was clear the Democrats
had vastly outperformed
expectations,
Republicans still had not taken
control of the House or Senate,
as expected,
Lindell let the world know
he had found the bad guys
who did all the fraud and stuff.
By the way,
see if you can follow any
of this completely
incoherent word vomit.
-I want to bring in
Mike Lindell.
Mike, you got some
interesting results
you wanted to share.
Go ahead.
-Yeah. Well, first of all,
when you guys
were talking before,
I was listening to you.
Who attacked our country
and what is this all about?
It's the CCP, the UNA party,
the deep state, the globalists,
and, now, the Democrat Party
joining with all of them.
Here's what we have.
In our real-time crime desk,
if you have a graphic to put up,
I'm going to show you
just one of them
and this is
Herschel Walker here.
[ Laughter ]
So, we're watching these races.
Vance was one.
I believe, early on,
they were taking it,
taking Vance,
and I think they just didn't put
any injection
because he totally overran
the algorithm.
We're watching these races
and it's like real-time crime.
I call it a crime spike.
And then you get
these crime spikes.
[ Laughter ]
-Jesus, dude. Mike Lindell's
the only guy I can think of
who would get cut off
at Starbucks.
[ Laughter ]
"Sir, I think you've had
enough macchiatos.
Let me call you a cab."
[ As Lindell ]
No, thanks. I'll just fly home.
[ Laughter ]
Real-time crime line.
He's like McGruff, if someone
put meth in his kibble.
[ Laughter ]
Here's a pretty good way
to track how well
the Democrats are doing --
the better the night they have,
the more incoherent
Mike Lindell gets.
In 2020, Lindell was like,
"There's fraud in the machines."
Very simple.
Now, the Republicans
and, specifically, Trump,
have gotten crushed again,
he's spitting out and vomiting
a bunch of meaningless nonsense
at lightning speed,
like an Amazon Echo
that got dropped in the toilet.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, Alexa,
can you give me
an election update?
-China CCP, UNA party,
global deep state, Dominion,
CIA voting machines hacked
are cybercrime spike
through the real-time
cybercrime cyberdesk.
Cyber, cyber, cyber, cyber,
[ Laughter ]
cyber, cyber,
-Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, and also,
who did the Dolphins
beat this weekend?
-Da Bears.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
-So, Lindell is blaming...
[ Laughter ]
...fraud, but many other
right-wing pundits
are looking elsewhere
for suspects.
On Fox News, for example,
they're blaming the fact
that no one seems
to hate Joe Biden.
-There's just not the hatred
for Joe Biden
that there is for Barack Obama
and for the Clintons.
There's not a Hate Biden vote
that's out there.
You know, when you go,
Trump's on the ballot,
there's that Hate Trump
Democrat vote?
People just don't feel the same
passion against the guy.
-I love watching it dawn
on Fox News in real time
that the stuff
they've been saying
for over two years is
total bull[bleep].
[ Laughter ]
It's like watching someone's
face drop on "Love is Blind"
when the reveal happens and...
[ Laughter ]
...they realize they're not
into the person
they're engaged to.
You dips spent two full years
talking about impeaching Biden
and claiming
he was actually, somehow,
the nefarious mastermind
behind a shadowy plot
to flood the country
with street gangs,
make America Communist,
indoctrinate our children
with wokeism,
and turn the military into
a gender studies class
at Bryn Mawr.
Nobody bought it.
Even the graphics you aired
to make him look scary
actually made him look cooler
than he was, like this one.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They mocked up with Biden
eating ice cream
in front of a burning building.
That actually aired on Fox.
Biden doesn't look evil.
He looks like he just snarled,
"Get off my plane,"
before kicking Gary Oldman
off Air Force One.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You don't have to like Biden
to know he's not
some Chairman Mao-type
revolutionary.
He's a 79-year-old man
from Scranton
who takes the train to work
and, occasionally,
gets stuck onstage
[ Laughter ]
or trips on the stairs
to Air Force One
three times in a row!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Fox News viewers
might hate Democrats,
but they are the age demographic
that, when they see Biden,
they can't help but think,
[ Gruffly ]
"Ah, he's one of us."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Fox News tries
to make him a villain
when he'd make
a far better spokesperson
in one of their commercials.
[ Laughter ]
But the stair video
was actually a clue.
That should've been a sign,
right there,
that Biden was better at this
than we all thought.
Even when he falls, he falls up.
[ Laughter ]
You know, if Trump had tripped
on the stairs,
he would've somehow rolled
all the way down to the Potomac,
where they'd have to fish him
out using a pool scoop.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That was not the only reason,
according to Fox,
for Biden's performance
last night.
Apparently, it's also the fault
of people who live in cities,
single women, and young voters.
-Single women are voting
for Democrats by 30 points,
-37.
-37 points!
-Yeah.
-In urban America.
They're cleaning our clocks
in the cities,
cleaning our clocks!
I'm not saying anything
nefarious is going on,
but they are cleaning our clocks
in the cities
[ Laughter ]
and we're giving it away.
And the fact that these youth
voters are coming in so strong
on an off-year
is very concerning.
It looks like
they've been brainwashed.
[ Laughter ]
This new generation
is totally brainwashed.
-Yeah, all these 25-year-old
Gen Z TikTokers
have been totally brainwashed
by 79-year-old
[ Laughter and applause ]
Joe Biden?
That's why the kids are all
doing the Joe Biden Challenge,
where you try to eat
an entire ice cream cone
before the burning house
behind you melts it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The dumbest part came later,
when Watters pitched a solution
to Republicans' problems
with single women --
just make the single women
get married.
-Single women are breaking
for Democrats by 30 points!
And this makes sense,
when you think
about how Democrat policies
are designed
to keep women single.
[ Pats desk ]
[ Laughter ]
But once women get married,
they vote Republican.
Married women, married men,
go for Republicans
by double digits.
But single women,
and voters under 40
have been captured by Democrats.
So, we need these ladies
to get married.
[ Laughter and ohhs ]
And it's time to fall in love
and just settle down.
Guys... [ Pats desk ]
go put a ring on it.
[ Laughter and ohhs ]
-I...doubt single women
are going to take advice
from a guy
who looks like he'd walk up
to you at a bar and ask,
"Did it hurt?"
But then forget
"when you fell from heaven"
and scramble
to finish the line, anyway.
[ As Watters ]
Did it hurt?
"Did what hurt?"
You know, when you fell.
"Fell where?"
Uh...
up the stairs?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, dudes, let me give you
all a little advice.
Just because you put
a ring on it,
don't expect your spouse's
opinions on politics --
or anything, for that matter --
to more closely align
with yours.
I've been married for nine years
and, mysteriously,
my wife still can't seem to find
any space in our apartment
for my artwork.
Why do you think I still have
all this [bleep] on my desk?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Because I'm not allowed
to bring it home.
We have a perfectly good
coffee table with nothing on it!
[ Laughter ]
And yet, somehow there's no room
for my Andy Samberg "My doink
fell off" mummy statue.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, but, yeah,
I'm going to convince her
to listen
to my political opinions.
She doesn't even watch the show
and, when I asked her why
she doesn't watch, she said,
"Our TV doesn't get NBC."
[ Laughter ]
That can't be right.
We have --
We have Peacock.
[ Laughter ]
By the way, Fox News
was not the only observer
of Tuesday's midterms
who seems to have drawn
the conclusion
that voters just don't hate
Joe Biden that much.
Biden himself seems
to have come away
with some renewed confidence,
as he made clear
in a press conference
at the White House yesterday,
where he was asked how he would
change his presidency
going forward,
based on the results,
and gave a very succinct answer.
-What, in the next two years,
do you intend to do differently
to change people's opinion
of the direction of the country,
particularly, as you contemplate
a run for president in 2024?
-Nothing.
[ Laughter ]
-My dude is feeling it!
I wouldn't have been shocked if,
right after he said that,
Dr. Jill sped through
on a Harley
and he just jumped on the back.
[ Laughter ]
Also, how great is it
to have short answers
at a press conference
after four years
of president Alphabet Soup
over here?
[ Laughter ]
If you asked Trump
that same question, he'd say --
[ As Trump ]
What am I going to do to change?
I'll tell you
who should change --
the crooked Democrats
because what they're doing,
they're ruining this country
with the crime and the windmills
and the windmills
committing crime.
[ Laughter ]
Some people are saying
the windmills are forming gangs
in New York City, now,
subway gangs.
[ Laughter ]
The windmills,
they go in the subway
and they pick your pocket
and it's easy for them
because, when you think
about it,
they have three arms, you know?
[ Laughter ]
They wave at you with two
and then the other one
grabs the wallet.
[ Laughter ]
When you try to stop them,
they just blow you back
with their wind.
[ Laughter ]
So, when it comes to changes,
if I'm being honest --
and I do want
to wrap up this answer --
[ Laughter ]
when it comes to changes,
I think the great David Bowie
said it back --
"Turn and face the strange,
ch-ch-ch-ch-changes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Don't want to be a richer man,"
but of course I do,
I do want to be a richer man,
So, on that point, David and I
will have to agree to disagree.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, right-wing pundits cycled
through every excuse
they could think of
for their poor performance --
voting machines, young people,
single women, cities --
but, eventually, they did land
on one explanation
that seems more in the ballpark
of reality -- Donald Trump.
Trump's clown car of bozos
and doofuses
got creamed on Tuesday.
Pro-Trump weirdos running
for House and Senate
got crushed,
especially compared
to the more traditional
Republican candidates
who've distanced themselves
from Trump.
Even Lauren Boebert
is struggling to hang on
in a safe Republican seat
that no one thought
was competitive.
I'm not saying I was psyched
when I saw Boebert was
in a tight race,
but when they flashed
those numbers on election night,
I turned to my wife and said...
-I'm staying up all night,
'til we win!
[ Laughter and applause ]
And then she said,
"Take that mummy back
to the office!"
[ Laughter ]
It's a conversation piece!
And, sure enough, the knives
are now out for Trump,
as the right-wing media
that fueled his rise to stardom,
in the first place,
turns on him,
including some of his longtime
fanboys at Fox News.
-It looks like we're --
in all likelihood,
we could be at the status quo,
a 50/50 Senate again.
If that happens, Donald Trump
cost us the presiden--
the Senate twice in a row.
-Donald Trump's not going
to like this,
but I got to tell you,
the people I talk to,
they say, "We love Donald Trump.
We're so grateful
that he beat Hillary Clinton.
We love his policies.
We think it's unfair,
how the media's treated him.
It's unfair, what the Department
of Justice has treated him.
But you know what?
We don't like all the drama.
We like Ron DeSantis."
That's what I hear.
-Does Trump win?
I hope so.
I love the guy.
And, a week ago, I would've said
slam dunk. [ Pats desk ]
But after how last night
shook out, I don't know now.
Democrats will walk over hot
coals to vote against Trump.
-So, going into 2024,
the Republicans are going
to be looking for candidates
who are focused on winning,
not just making a point
or settling a score.
The populist movement is
about ideas.
It is not about any one person.
If the voters conclude
that you're putting
your own ego
or your own grudges
ahead of what's good
for the country,
they're going to look
elsewhere, period.
-Trump is the past.
-Man, Republicans are running
away from Trump faster
than Josh Hawley on January 6th.
[ Laughter and applause ]
These guys went
from devoting themselves
to Trump for over six years
to suddenly
tossing him overboard
in the span of 24 hours.
I got to say, it's fun to watch.
Fox News versus Trump is like
"Alien vs. Predator"
or "Godzilla vs. Kong"
or Biden versus stairs.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guess what.
He's not just going
to magically go away,
especially after you spent six
years slavishly supporting him.
He's Donald Trump.
He's incapable
of keeping his mouth shut
for longer than five seconds.
Dude can't even stand still.
Whenever he has to pose
for a photo op,
he does that thing
where he sways back and forth,
[ Laughter ]
like a drunk guy
on a cruise ship
that's caught in a storm.
[ Laughter ]
The GOP might
suddenly want
to cut ties with Trump,
but for Republicans,
Donald Trump is like Jason --
nothing you can do stops him.
Plus, you know,
he always looks like
he just drowned in a lake
at a summer camp.
[ Laughter ]
You guys created this monster
and, now, you're going
to have to live with them.
You don't just get
to wave it all away
and say stuff like this --
-Trump is the past.
-You wish he was!
It's too late, mother[bleep]!
[ Laughter and applause ]
You doinks could've helped
impeach and convict him
and you probably would've been
riding high
on a red tsunami Tuesday,
but, instead,
you had to kiss the ring.
House GOP Leader Kevin McCarthy,
who hopes to be
the next speaker,
if Republicans eke out
a majority in the House,
even flew down to Mar-A-Lago
for that photo op,
like two real estate agents
who are trying to sell you
a house on haunted
burial ground.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
You have the ghosts
and the ghouls.
We love the ghouls.
[ Laughter ]
And the ghouls,
they'll wail all night
and rattle their chains,
but look at the high ceilings
and, you know, it's close
to good schools and shopping.
[ Laughter ]
Voters, once again,
repudiated the MAGA movement
and Trumpism on Tuesday,
just as they did
in 2018 and 2020,
and now, suddenly,
the same Republicans
who marched in lockstep
behind Trump for six years,
wreaking havoc on the nation,
want to cut ties and run away
from him as fast as they can.
The Trumpified GOP has alienated
everyone from women
to suburban voters,
to people in cities;
to young voters, who are
especially hard to poll
because they don't answer
phone calls.
They prefer to communicate...
-By cyber.
-This has been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
..."A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]